[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 0 0 artistes femmes
représentées sur ses illustrations d'art
préhistorique que je viens de vous
montrer et pourtant j'en ai cherchés
récemment je suis tombé sur un article
évoquant un biologiste anglais john
manning
il a étudié la forme des mains lieu des
durées des différences dans la forme des
mains entre les hommes et les femmes une
histoire de longueur de doigts entre
l'index et l'annulaire
il en aurait déduit que 80% de ses
empreintes réalisés dans les grottes
auraient été créées par des femmes
d'ailleurs que ce soit scientifiquement
vrai peu importe ici pour moi ce qui
compte c'est l'implicite de la figure de
l'artiste hommes
quand j'avais 7 ans j'ai décidé tout
seul de devenir droitière alors mes
parents et ma maîtresse ou encouragé
dans ce projet ils m'ont soutenu et
m'ont même valorisé je me suis entraîné
pendant des semaines et peut-être
quelques mois ont clairement c'était
contre nature est quasi impossible
au final je suis resté gauchère je crois
que là ma carrière de petites filles
modèles qui répondent aux implicite
c'est à dire aux attentes sans même
qu'on les lui formule a commencé à
dévier de trajectoire l'implicite ici
c'était quoi à elle est gauchère
bon c'est pas grave si c'est pas grave
c'est quand même un peu gênant voire
décevant je précise quand même que je
suis la première génération qu'on a
autorisé à une gauchère avant c'était
tout simplement interdit puisque la main
gauche représentait le diable ou quelque
chose comme ça je suis devenu artiste
plasticienne et performeuse donc je crée
des oeuvres au croisement de l'art
contemporain l'art numérique
la performance et le spectacle vivant
des oeuvres comme celle ci qui
s'intitule l'année postérieur nets
l'année mondiale de l'indicent
postérieur net et du bonheur national
brut
je ne vous montre qu'une vidéos
documentant cette oeuvre c'est pas
vraiment l'oeuvre et j'ai pas son plu
j'ai choisi pas mettre le son donc il ya
ce fut pitre que vous avez vu que vous
pouvez déclencher pour voir des
documents d'archivés ou des animations
ces images sons vidéos projetées sur de
faux meubles en carton il y à de vrais
gravure et du dessin fait directement
sur le mur
je mets une image fixe parce que sinon
il paraît que c'est compliqué de
m'écouter en même temps qu'en tant
qu'artiste je m' articule je m'intéresse
à l'articulation entre le documentaire
et l'art est plus qu'une dénonciation
mes oeuvres sont une forme d'accès au
savoir
alors serre si elle porte ce qu'est le
savoir elle porte sur la quantification
du ressenti par les grandes institutions
je précise c'est quand l'onu l'insee et
eurostat quantifie le bonheur le
bien-être la satisfaction et même le
sens de la vie parce que ça se quantifie
donc elle porte sur la pas rentable
surdité de quantifier ce qui peut
sembler inquantifiable ça a commencé
comme ça j'étais dans le métro je lisais
le journal gratuit et julie aïe aïe aïe
la france qui était 32e dans le
classement mondial du bonheur de l'onu
poursuit sa chute à temps elle était 28e
elle est passée 32e sur 157 pays et
c'est les émirats arabes unis qui ont
pris sa 28e place
ben voyons autant vous dire qu'en tant
que femme j'ai bondi alors j'ai fait des
recherches
je voulais essayer de comprendre puis
j'ai continué mes recherches et j'ai
fait encore d'autres recherches et j'ai
trouvé que ce classement mondial du
bonheur de l'onu il est établi à partir
des données de la société privée
américaine galope qui établit des
données en permanence dans le monde
entier auprès d'échantillons
représentatifs de population
j'ai parcouru beaucoup de questionnaires
j'ai trouvé très peu de questions sur
les femmes mais j'ai trouvé celle ci la
question wp 90,50 do you believe we may
and you can't we aren't whittier de vue
respecte indigné en note
croyez vous que dans votre pays les
femmes sont traitées avec dignité et
respect ou pas mais c'est quoi cette
question
trop facile tout le monde peut répondre
oui à cette question
et ben oui des émirats arabes unis à la
france de la colombie à la thaïlande
on peut toujours considérer que les
femmes sont très bien traités avec
dignité et respect
la même question est posée juste avant
pour les enfants et vraisemblablement
les hommes échappent à ce type de
questionnement ils ne seraient pas
concernés peut-être par des problèmes de
dignité ou de respect bref je travaille
dans le milieu de l'art et de la culture
un milieu qui se pensent naturellement
éclairé avant gardiste à la pointe de la
contemporanéité et j'y ai cru longtemps
en 1990 à l'école des beaux-arts de
paris
on était de nombreuses étudiantes et
quasi que des professeurs hommes les
expositions exposé des hommes et puis
les médailles récompensé des hommes mais
je croyais en l'autorégulation
surtout que quelques années avant les
guerrilla girls avait déjà souligné le
contraste abyssal entre le nombre de
femmes et d'hommes exposés par les
institutions et vous l'avez compris il
n'y a pas eu d'autorégulation ça n'a
quasi pas changé en trente ans je lisais
récemment ce rapport du haut conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
il date de 2018 et il porte sur les arts
et la culture
alors tous les arts 1 c'est-à-dire les
beaux-arts mais aussi le cinéma la
littérature la bande dessinée
larchitecture théâtre musique danse
bon il y en a cent trente quatre pages
je vous montre seulement le tableau de
synthèse
donc on est en 2018 on a toujours 60%
des étudiants eux dans les écoles art et
culture on n'a que 40 % de femmes
professionnelles toutes professions
confondues
il n'y a que 20 % d'artistes femmes
aidées par des fonds publics
il n'y a que 20 % l'artiste femmes
programmés et 10% du coût d'artistes
femmes récompensées et médaillé 80 20
alors pourquoi on l'a vu il ya ce mythe
de la figure de l'artiste homme et un
autre mythe intéressant qui évoque ce
rapport c'est le mythe du talent
aurier parce que nous les artistes et
ben on serait doté comme ça d'un génie
d'un don ou d'un talon et puis la
croyance et que si vous avez un grand
talent et bien vous fait une grande
carrière mais qui décide du talent
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme idéologie et
comme valeur derrière le talent pour
qu'ils tombent principalement sur des
hommes blancs quadras quinquas et
sexagénaires
[Musique]
parce que ce fameux talent si vous avez
de moins bonnes conditions de travail
comme dans tous les autres milieux
professionnels ça impacte la qualité du
travail est l'oeuvre sera moins aboutie
et ça le public
ils le voient et le rapport le quantifie
très bien les femmes sont moins
subventionnés - programmée et moins
récompensés donc une réalisatrice de
films réalise des films avec un budget
plus bas une directrice d'institutions
culturelles dirige un lieu moins dotés
financièrement et les oeuvres d'artistes
plasticienne sont moins acheté et
acheter moins cher
en gros l'argent public continue d'être
principalement redistribués aux hommes
est beaucoup moins aux femmes
c'est à dire c'est quand même 80 20 il
ya un autre point intéressant qu'aborde
le rapport c'est celui des horaires
atypiques parce que le travail le soir
et le week end dans le milieu de l'art
et la culture
eh bien c'est la norme et ça ce serait
vraiment pénalisant pour les artistes
femmes et mères personne n'évoque le
moindre souci pour les artistes hommes
et pères mais oui parce que dans ce
milieux éclairés comme dans tous les
autres milieux
la répartition des rôles parentale n'est
pas vraiment plus équitable alors bien
sûr on n'est pas dans les années 50 les
hommes maintenant font les courses la
cuisine
il donne le bain on sait mieux que c'est
mieux
mais comme dans tous les milieux
je porte cette fameuse charge mentale
c'est à dire que je suis obligé
d'anticiper d'organiser tous et je suis
prêt posé je sais pas pourquoi mais je
suis préposé à tout ce qui est scolaire
administratif et médical
donc je suis préposé à l'achat des
fournitures scolaires
l'étiquetage des fringues pour la
colonie de vacances l'organisent les
rendez vous chez l'orthophoniste
orthoptistes l'orthodontiste
l'inscription sport certif médical
compris la collecte de matériaux pour le
projet quatre saisons de la maîtresse
samedi quelque chose vous aussi vous
l'avez eue les quatre saisons trier les
fringues trop petit
aussi voyez où par exemple organiser les
anniversaires programmer les prochaines
vacances avant que celles d'avant soit
bien terminé
tout ça quoi j'arrête là mais il ya un
truc qui me dérange souvent c'est que
voyez par exemple une infirmière elle a
aussi des horaires atypiques
peut-être même beaucoup plus que moi
fréquemment mais elle est courageuse sa
vocation à elle elle est légitime
l idée vous aux autres mais combien de
fois moi en tant qu'artiste j'ai entendu
ah ouais mais toi c'est ta passion
avec ce tee s'entendent sous-entendu
culpabilisant pas de pain pâté
difficultés à gérer des horaires
atypiques un tu as choisi d'être mère et
artistes d'être dévoué à ton art donc
comme quoi c'est pas très légitime
d'être mère et artistes en même temps je
suis donc artistes femmes mères
célibataires c'est assez fréquent dans
le milieu de l'art et j'ai deux enfants
je suis prêt si ça parce que dans ce
milieu d'eux c'est beaucoup et ça
surprend et j'ai la cinquantaine qui
approche
autant vous dire que j'ai pas le profil
du poste quoi
j'ai un profil mais alors pas du tout
rassurant pas du tout rassurant voir qui
serait déjà classé sans suite
alors qu'on pourrait me voir comme
incarnant le mythe de l'héroïne
contemporaine il y a dix ans à la
naissance de sa fille
mon ami artiste jeanne susplugas ce a
perdu deux de ses galeries en septembre
dernier j'étais à berlin
je discutais avec une commissaire
d'exposition que je venais de rencontrer
on se connaissait vraiment pas du tout
est dans le flou de la discussion comme
ça elle me sort mais comme une évidence
une évidence ils fouillent raf kédougou
facteurs pnue et si on a des enfants on
est foutu de toute façon un nom mais en
prenant du recul c'est quand même assez
dingue lan 6 super violent et en plus
c'est plus compliqué que ça cette
histoire de maternité parentalité il
suffirait même pas dire bon ben je vais
pas d'enfant je vais faire une grande
carrière d'homme est resté dans
l'histoire de l'art non il ya un revers
de la médaille il ya même plusieurs
revers il ya une historienne de l'art
maria traces fort inique et une
hypothèse intéressante elle a étudié les
conditions de vie des graves deux
anglaises et américaines du 19e siècle
qui était très renommé à l'époque de mon
nom a disparu
elle a constaté que ces graveuse était
plus célibataire que leurs collègues
masculins que si elle était mariée elle
avait moins d'enfants et qu'elle était
veuve plus tôt et à leur mort il y a pas
eu de descendance pour conserver et
transmettre la mémoire de leur travail
et leurs noms sont tombés dans l'oubli
un autre exemple plus récent milieu du
xxème siècle les années 50
le célèbre artiste américain jackson
pollock connu pour sa technique du
dripping qui consistait à faire couler
de l'encré de la peinture sur sa toile
il reconnaît s'être inspiré de l'artiste
jeannette sobel dont il avait vu
l'étoile en 1944 dans une galerie à new
york et l'historienne de l'art béatrice
joyeux prunelle le formule très bien
c'est quelque chose à peu près comme ça
elle dit on n'était pas prêt à ce que le
mythe de l'avant garde américaine puisse
être incarné par une mère de quatre
enfants immigrés d'origine ukrainienne
on n'était pas prêt
pourquoi c'est important en fait qu'il y
ait toujours plus de femmes artistes et
qu'elle soit surtout plus reconnu
pourquoi c'est important parce qu après
tout peut-être que ce fonctionnement
interne du milieu de l'art de la culture
spectacle vivant peut-être que ce
fonctionnement interne il est très loin
de vos préoccupations
mais tant qu'il y'aura majoritairement
des artistes hommes on verra toujours
les mêmes représentations stéréotypées
véhicules et les mêmes rapports de
domination et ça sera toujours plus
compliqué pour une femme comme pour un
homme de se sentir légitime est libre de
faire d'autres choix
il faudrait une autre conférence en fait
pour simplement lister toutes les
représentations stéréotypées
mais je garderai ce soir qu'un exemple
implicitement un homme s'il travaille
dans le même domaine que sa compagne il
gagne plus qu'elle est à plus de
reconnaissance professionnelle
j'ai plusieurs amis homme qui avoue
faire la vaisselle pas de souci organisé
et accompagné une sortie scolaire s'est
même valorisant mais imaginez un jour
gagner moins qu'elle en travaillant dans
le même domaine
ça ce serait mais ingérable on n'est
toujours pas prêt de voir au cinéma
comme dans la vraie vie' la chirurgienne
avec la firme avec avec l'infirmier de
voir la commissaire de police avec
l'adjoint de sécurité et encore moins de
voir la chef d'orchestre avec le second
violon on n'est toujours pas prêt au
printemps dernier je déjeunais avec mon
père j'ai évoqué ce rapport du haut
conseil à l'égalité que je vous ai
présenté au tout début et un petit peu
comme tout le monde
bah oui les connaît ces inégalités c'est
bon on en entend parler est un peu comme
tout le monde je voyais bien qu'ils ne
mesuraient pas l'ampleur de ces
inégalités 80 20 % je lui propose de lui
envoyer le rappeur et il me répond non
moi ce soir dans mon télérama je compte
les films réalisés par les femmes et le
lendemain j'ai reçu un mail dans lequel
il m'écrivait
j'ai compté mais tu as raison c'est
massif
alors je vous propose tout simplement de
comté compter les femmes dans les
expositions collectives compter les
expositions monographiques de femmes
compter les femmes réalisatrices et pas
que comédienne comptait aussi les
comédiennes quadras quinquas et
sexagénaires compter les chansons
écrites par des femmes et pas seulement
chanté par des femmes compter les
groupes de rock de hard ou de punk
féminin compter les femmes chefs
d'orchestre compter les femmes poètes et
autres i ce que vous avez lu compter les
femmes politiques comptaient les femmes
sur wikipédia et puis comptait aussi les
femmes récompensées avec une médaille
une coupe voir un trophée pourquoi
compter parce que conté s'est pas
seulement réduire les choses complexes
dans la de la vie en de vulgaires
chiffre compte et c'est aussi
émancipateur et comme le dit si bien
l'économiste florence jany-catrice tout
ce qui n'est pas content et finit par ne
plus compter alors oui c'est possible de
simplement compter pour rendre les
femmes visible oui c'est possible de
compter et n'hésitez pas à commenter et
à partager
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]